and finally new rule conservatives have
to admit they've lost the culture wars
when they're reduced to demanding the
right to not serve wedding cake to gay
people that's the biggest problem facing
America not climate change or terrorism
or the wealth gap but gay cake it's all
like gays are asking bakeries to make a
giant penis cake that goes from soft to
hard and squirts out buttercream which
reminds me the big party is tomorrow now
ever since Indiana Governor Mike Pence
signed his Religious Freedom Restoration
Act he and like-minded conservatives
have been trying to have it both ways
they hate discrimination but they love
the Bible a book that commands you to
discriminate that's what it says gays
and abomination and we must destroy it
by denying it pastry
of course the root of this problem is
that more than half of all Americans
still believe the Bible is the actual or
inspired Word of God but now 55% also
support gay marriage which must be very
confusing on the one hand clearly God
has spelled it out he hates [ __ ] but you
like your gay neighbors Robyn Larry but
the Bible tells you to kill them yes it
literally says kill them what to do well
if you're a Christian attorney Matt
McLaughlin from nearby Orange County you
write a ballot initiative which calls
for guilt
killing all the gay people in California
because to quote mr. McLaughlin better
that offenders should die rather than
that all of us should be killed by God's
just wrath now I know you're saying this
guy's so far out on the fringe but
that's the scary thing he's not and this
is what never gets discussed in these
religious freedom issues the recent
fundamentalists are so stubbornly
anti-gay is they truly believe that
condoning homosexuality will bring on
God's wrath this is what Jerry Falwell
used to preach he said AIDS was God's
punishment for a society that tolerates
homosexuals and that gays and lesbians
helped 9/11 happened John Hagee said God
caused Hurricane Katrina to wipe out New
Orleans because it had a gay pride
parade the week before Pat Robertson
warned Orlando
home of Disneyworld that if they went
ahead with the gay themed promotion
it'll bring about terrorist bombs
earthquakes tornadoes and possibly a
meeting or possibly a meteor he's not a
good
just two weeks ago Bob Jones the third
founding scientist Jim Bob Jones
University apologized for a comment he
once made which was it would not be a
bad idea if gay people were stoned as
the Bible commands take fundamentalist
at their word they literally believe
this stuff and if you believe that God
wiped out Sodom and Gomorrah for being
too gay then yeah he must be itching to
hit West Hollywood
is California really going to consider
mr. McLaughlin is gay killin Bill of
course not
but as batshit as this [ __ ] is just
imagine if there was a whole country of
Matt mcLaughlin well there is
it's called Saudi Arabia it's called
Iran it's called Pakistan I could go on
but suffice it to say that in many
Muslim countries you wouldn't have to
work hard at all to get signatures on
your kill all the gays ballot initiative
in 10 such countries it's already the
law because because they have crazy
scripture - Mohammed says of sodomy
killed the one who does it and the one
to whom it is done especially him
because he probably likes it more
he didn't say that part
people say Isis hijacked Islam no
actually the opposite is true
religions do have hijackers but the
hijackers are the moderates and I thank
a theist God for them they're the ones
who took a Sharpie to the Bible and
redacted all the crazy parts until there
was almost nothing left to read like an
email from Hillary Clinton and now
someone in Islam needs to do that with
the Quran you know there's so much wrong
with America these days take pride in
the one thing that is legitimately
better we don't let fundamentalist rule
our [ __ ]
once the proof our gay battles are over
cake and even then not once has one of
these religious freedom law has been
used to deny a gay person his wedding
cake it just doesn't happen what happens
is there's a lawsuit it goes to court
and the judge always says [ __ ] just
make the cake
you